déjà coalition ça veut dire quoi
concrètement parce qu'on met dedans
pardon qu'est-ce qu'on met dedans
qu'est-ce qu'on met dedans pour
l'instant ce sont des mots on verra si
il y aura un changement de méthode parce
que ce qu'il manque dans cette
allocution c'est quelle nouvelle méthode
j'apporte pour clairement porter les
réformes qui sont assez ambitieuses les
trois grandes trois grandes dossiers les
trois grands chantiers sont très
ambitieux on parle de réforme de la
justice réforme du travail mais cela dit
on est toujours dans une majorité pour
leur relative et la deuxième question
qui se pose c'est est-ce qu'on peut
porter ces trois grands chantiers avec
le même gouvernement avec la même
première ministre qui a quand même été
assez abîmé dans dans le cadre de cette
séquence des retraites donc c'est toutes
ces questions là en suspens qui me
laisse un peu perplexe même si le cap
clairement il y a une barre à droite
quoi qu'on en dise je ne vais pas
cracher sur la réforme de la justice ou
sur la réforme de l'école pardon la
justice c'est pas de droite ni de gauche
sans vraiment
qu'à la barre est à droite puisqu'il a
compris clairement qu'il fallait au
minimum 40 députés LR pour asseoir une
majorité alors absolue vous voyez pas
forcément le coup de bar à droite